hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar laboratory diagnosis of immune
deficiency i am michelle ashton of lab
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by binding sites to learn more about
our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor muon during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational ms offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. sarah
wheeler assistant professor at the
university of pittsburgh associate
medical director clinical
immunopathology
at UPMC Children's Hospital of
Pittsburgh and the medical director of
automated testing laboratory at UPMC
Mercy and UPMC Children's Hospital of
Pittsburgh for complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr. really your men begin your
presentation thank you so much Michelle
good morning and thank you so much for
attending our discussion of the
laboratory diagnosis of immune
deficiency as mentioned I oversee
clinical immunopathology as well as the
automated testing laboratory at
Children's Hospital of Pittsburgh
so weekly I'm consulting with clinicians
regarding primary immunodeficiencies so
this is a topic near and dear to my
heart so today we have a few learning
objectives hopefully we're going to
understand the role of laboratory
testing in diagnosing primary
immunodeficiency disorders we're also
looking to be able to outline
appropriate test unit utilization and
primary immunodeficiency disorder
screening lastly we want to identify
limitations and test utilization and
implementation for primary
immunodeficiency disorders
so a quick overview of PID or primary
immunodeficiency they're about a quarter
of a million people with PID in the u.s.
unfortunately many still remain
undiagnosed it's an under diagnosed
disease with estimates that 70 to 90% of
people with PID don't even know that
they have it
PID itself is a genetic disorder that
impairs the immune system genetic
defects we've been missing or
dysfunctional immune system components
the immune system defects can remain
undetected due to know clinically
significant symptoms or it can be life
life-threatening ly severe the spectrum
is wide and the number of primary
immunodeficiencies is currently over 300
identified and Counting there's a lot of
expansion happening here due to the
increased availability of genetic
testing aside from our patients that
have no clinically significant disease
manifestations there are many more that
remain undiagnosed because the signs and
symptoms often look much like normal
childhood diseases or in some cases
adults infections or diseases
there are many warning signs that might
look like standard childhood illnesses
that we should pay attention for if
there are four or more new ear
infections within a year two or more
serious sinus infections within a year
two or more months on antibiotics with
little effect of the antibiotics on the
infection two or more pneumonias within
a year failure of an infant to gain
weight or grow normally which accounts
for most of the cases we see at
Children's Hospital but combined with
some of these other indications can be
cause for concern
recurrent deep skin or organ abscesses
persistent thrush in the mouth or fungal
infection on the skin any need for IV
antibiotics to clear infections should
raise red flags for us two or more
deep-seated infections including
septicemia and since the PID is a
genetic disorder any family history
should really prompt increased attention
to be a - PID diagnosis so there are
four stages of testing that have been
outlined the Jeffrey modo foundation has
pulled together a large number of PID s
experts to be able to develop these four
stages that are listed here these can
help get the appropriate diagnosis much
faster also preventing many of the
complications that often come from an
undiagnosed PID looking just at stage
one which is history and physical exam
including weight and height a CBC with
disqualifies immunoglobulin levels with
the age appropriate interval if
estimated about 75% of PID s can be
diagnosed looking at just this stage one
the CBC can be particularly helpful as a
first look at PCL and phagocytic related
deficiencies while the quantitative
immunoglobulins or Qi G's can provide a
first look at these so related defects
stage 2 starts to get a little bit more
specific we're looking at specific
antibody responses to vaccines most
subjects vaccines are administered with
very stringent regulation of dosage how
much adjuvant is present to route and
schedule so evaluation of a vaccine
response through the measurement of
their antibody titers in serology can
provide some measurement of antigen
standardization between patient
populations some patients have antibody
failure against bacterial polysaccharide
antigens are able to respond to
immunization with protein antigens and
in the opposite direction as well so the
measurement of IgG subclasses
concentrations is fairly standard and
can help in understanding some of these
immunization responses it's also
standard for us to look at subclasses in
the suspicion of any antibody deficiency
particularly when the total IgG is
within that normal age specific
reference range the measurement of these
subclasses is also useful for the
diagnosis of IgG subclass deficiency
specifically and to aid in the diagnosis
of specific antibody deficiencies as a
supporting test for common variable
immunodeficiency and then we also use it
for some risk stratification of patients
that have iga specific deficiencies so
our stages 1 & 2 are covering most of
the common pids but stages 3 & 4 begin
to tease out some of the less common
primary immunodeficiencies including
cellular and phagocytic deficiencies
they are also looking to narrow the
specific deficiency mechanism so as we
move into stage three t-cell disorders
can be confirmed by a lack of delayed
hypersensitivity skin testing response
specifically we asked him look at
Candida mumps or tetanus obviously only
in children older than one year who have
actually been exposed to those three
vaccines or
environment lymphocytes subtest analysis
can also be used at any age and screens
for the number and percentage of T cells
B cells and natural killer cells those
are the surface markers that are listed
Linds ones
like proliferation studies also look at
t-cell function which provides insight
into cellular and combined
immunodeficiency also determines para
t-cell function by culturing human
peripheral blood mononuclear cells we do
that in vitro with my digits and
antigens and that is usually assessed by
flow cytometry stage form moves into
testing for more specific and less
common deficiencies and is usually
requested with us specifically by
clinical immunologists laboratory
testing is critical in quickly and
accurately diagnosing primary mineral
deficiency disorders stage testing helps
us provide a rapid rule in or rule out
diagnosis and prevents this kind of
testing anemia that we often see and our
tiny patients at Children's Hospital
when we take far too many samples for
this model amount of blood that they
have
so looking at the classification of PID
as well as its distribution there are
official PID classification criteria
that has been agreed upon by the
International Union of immunological
societies expert committee for the
classification of primary
immunodeficiency and these particular
numbers come from physician reporting on
PID that was used in a survey again
performed by the Jeffrey module centers
Network and it helps provide a bit of an
indication of current disease
distributions in the US and globally the
predominant antibody diffidently
antibody deficiencies account for the
majority of PID is about half
that said an inherent bias and that data
is that all of these are diagnosed cases
because they are reported by physicians
combined immunodeficiencies and other
unspecified deficiencies accounted for
the next largest group by the Civic
defects account for less of its
percentage than I've actually seen in
other reports I'm not sure if this is
due to sampling bias or changes with
time but there is a sense that if I had
said phagocytic defects may actually be
a bit higher than listed here
so when we're thinking about primary
immunodeficiencies it helps to step back
and take a simplified look at the immune
system immune response can be broken
down into the innate and acquired and
acquired immunity innate immunity
doesn't require a prior exposure to an
action so it can respond immediately
it recognizes primary we generalized
antigen molecules rather than antigens
specific to an organism or cell
components includes complement
phagocytic cells that be our nutri
neutrophils monocytes macrophages that
all of these work to ingest and destroy
invading antigens natural killer cells
polymorphonuclear leukocytes again
neutrophils to gets nfl's basophils as
well as mononuclear cells monocytes
macrophages mast cells these all release
inflammatory mediators acquired immunity
on the other hand take some time to
develop after the initial exposure but
with a new antics after the initial
exposure with a new antigen but after
that first exposure the immune system is
much quicker to respond to because it
has memory so the acquired immunity
includes t-cells which would be so
mediated immunity and b-cells which we
often termed humoral immunity so immune
cells differentiate from stem cells in
the bone marrow which we see starting at
the top of the slide and at each step of
the differentiation the cells become
increasingly specialized and in each of
the steps there are opportunities for
genetic defects to throw a wrench in the
works and create what we now term
primary immunodeficiencies so here we
have a few of the origins of PID defects
again there are over 300 of these so
we're not doing a comprehensive look at
that but as you can see of each stage
mutations in the gene can cause defects
in downstream immune functions some
mutations can affect multiple systems
and some have effects beyond just the
immune system if you look at the ones in
black that are more towards the right of
the screen those are examples of
combined being t-cells primary
immunodeficiencies
with the most severe being reticular dis
Genesis at the top in Mereen are
examples are mostly b-cell related pids
and in red to the left are P IDs
associated with defects in phagocytic
cells
in red to the right is the PID
associated with primarily t-cell
function what you'll notice is that many
PA DS really have overlap between
classes than any of the classification
systems used and just another look at an
estimate of PID distribution this this
estimate actually also looks at
undiagnosed cases that creates an
estimate around undiagnosed cases and it
indicates again that these predominantly
antibody deficiencies account for a
little over half of P IDs with combined
immunodeficiencies and defects in
phagocytic cells following at about 10%
of all P IDs each this demonstrates
quite well why a CBC and a quantitative
immunoglobulin with a medical examine
history can really diagnose or perhaps a
little better to say identify about 75%
of P IDs so for my brain looking at the
very complex classification system can
be a little difficult on the day to day
basis as we are triaging cases that are
coming in and the testing that's being
done on them so I like to simplify the
classification a little bit so from the
differentiation of the immune system it
can be a bit easier mental shorthand to
think of P IDs in these simplified
categories looking at B so related
t-cell related combined complement and
bag acidic again not perfect categories
but they're useful as we start trying to
work through cases and I've listed a few
examples of these on the right for
reference
this is another reference another useful
way for us to think about primary
immunodeficiencies is associating them
with the indications for the disorders
so a few themes present here as you scan
down increased infections obviously and
in particular increased opportunistic
infections also infections that are more
severe in their course than you would
expect to see increased autoimmune
disease particularly eczema comes up
quite a bit as well as allergies
malignancy is also a common thing theme
among many primary immunodeficiencies
because the presentation of so many P I
DS has many symptoms that could be
somewhat normal in childhood the PID
community often identifies primarily
with Disney bruh so in addition to this
being a very adorable cartoon that's
really applicable to all ages kids and
adults can identify with the zebra it's
based on a thing that many of us learn
in our medical training that when we
hear hoofbeats we should think horses
not zebras
and we're really tough to focus on the
likeliest possibilities in the hand
diagnosis not the unusual ones and that
is often very sound advice however
sometimes we do need to look for the
zebra and people with PID are often the
Zebras in the medical world so with that
we're going to look at a few zebras
we're going to move into some cases that
have come through either the laboratory
or my clinical immunology counterparts
have addressed so case one is Timothy
obviously all of the case names are made
up
Timothy first presentation was at one
year of age he was born full-term
full-term didn't have any prior
hospitalizations no significant past
medical history this was his first time
really coming in for anything besides
wellness visits he comes from a
non-smoking household and doesn't attend
to day care he actually receives care in
his home of via grandparents and
part-time working parents he lives at
home with his parents and they do have
two puppies and he presented at the IDI
with a neck abscess of two centimeters
on the left side and a CT scan was done
and showed around enhancing that
he recently had what they suspected was
hand foot and mouth disease not at all
uncommon for his age he was admitted he
went to be a war where they drain desist
fist and looking at the fluid they found
that it was puffs and it was Gram stain
and found to be gram positive cocci and
the culture revealed that it was an MSS
a IV penicillin was given while he was
in the hospital and he was discharged on
amoxicillin one week later after being
discharged and while he was still on
antibiotics he returned with a three
centimeter mass that was just below the
incision site he was again admitted went
to the ER they drained it again and he
was just charged home a few days later
again on amoxicillin
one year later poor Timothy comes back
so he's had a month history of daily
fevers his father reported that he
initially noticed that Timothy felt warm
and started checking his temperature and
that over the last month they were
noticing that he had fevers generally
ranging at about 102 degrees Fahrenheit
that occurred mostly in the late
afternoon or evening he hadn't had other
significant symptoms and he'd been
healthy since his hospitalization a year
ago and his dad never really felt like
he looked sick throughout all of this
which is why they hadn't brought him in
before his history as well as the exam
that was done in the IDI were really
unrevealing for the origin of the fever
testing was sent out it came back and he
had normal electrolytes including
calcium and albumin as well as normal
liver function tests CBC and DIF were
essentially normal except that he did
have a mild anemia with a hemoglobin of
10 point 7 grams per deciliter
hematocrit of 32% and thrombus Tombo
cytosis with a platelet count of 315,000
the CRP was slightly elevated was
elevated slightly it was elevated at 6.7
mix per liter they also sent EBV titers
and bartonella titers and those were
both negative as was as urinalysis
it also decided to do some imaging so we
had to check chest x-ray an abdominal
ultrasound that was negative they looked
at tuberculosis testing that was
negative they decided to do an
echocardiogram so there was concern
about Kawasaki disease and there was
nothing consistent in the echocardiogram
with KD he did have a mildly elevated
ferritin but two blood cultures came
back negative and the CMV pcr was
negative they also sent out for
Toxoplasma serology that was negative
they did do a virus swab and that tested
positive for enterovirus and Rhino virus
but that didn't seem to explain his
illness they also did some stool testing
for ogen parasites that was negative so
they decided to order quantitative
immunoglobulins to look into this a
little more looking at this quantitative
immunoglobulins they were essentially
normal with just a slight increase in
IgM that wasn't really considered
significant on that Rheumatology was
called in for a consult and they added
juvenile idiopathic arthritis to the
differential which included the current
differential with including a closed
infection periodic fever syndrome as
well as movement C and fever is
sometimes seen in JEA
that the fevers are present for some
time prior to the onset of the arthritis
a rash and the possibility of periodic
fever syndrome couldn't really be
completely excluded but usually in that
the peepers are actually periodic and
not acute in on set and then persistent
as Timothy had been seeing and usually
periodic syndrome is accompanied by
other symptoms
there weren't any diagnosis given there
was no discrete symptom that could
really guide management so they wanted
to see if this could continue to become
a picture consistent with juvenile
idiopathic arthritis so Timothy was to
have it was going to have to be
monitored he his mom was to check him
for the signs of GI which included the
classic evanescent salmon-colored rashes
under his arms and his diaper
during fevers as well as keeping a diary
of any evidence of arthritis she was
discharged to home but a month later he
came back to the emergency department
this time he had a side a scented
abdomen
it had an unclear ideology his labs were
showing continued elevation of CRP and a
chronic microcytic anemia and apparently
I really wanted to be sure that it was
clear that this was microcytic as I
repeated that twice he also had a
persistent thrombocytosis and
hypoalbuminemia which could be
consistent with the general picture of
chronic inflammation that appeared to be
building the person Tisa's found the
ascites to be perience with a white cell
count of 10,000 which was consistent
with a next few date at this hospital
visit there was a new family history of
Crohn's disease as well so a few other
tests were sent the fluid cultures from
the ascites remained negative and it
appeared that overall this was
consistent with an inflammatory ideology
but it wasn't really clear if that was
inflammatory bowel disease or perhaps
systemic onset Jie
so at this point poor Timothy was
definitely at risk of becoming one of
our blood drawing and me Mia related
patients
he had a host of testing done and he was
already anemic and we probably worsened
that to date all of the testing had been
rule-out and he was negative for this
whole host of testing that included a
periodic fever genetic panel that was
sent out a CT scan of his abdomen was
consistent with peritonitis and due to
the findings of the CT scan as well as
secondary activities continued fevers
and abdominal distension they went ahead
and started him on antibiotics for the
possibility of spontaneous bacterial
peritonitis and he headed home about
four days into the antibiotic treatment
his fevers did stop which was helpful
another months later he was back he
again had ascites this time it contains
macrophages monocytes and acute
information markers it was decided to do
an exploratory laparoscopy with
paracentesis at that time they also did
a peritoneal biopsy liver biopsy as well
as colon and small vessel biopsy to try
to rule out or rule in something the
peroneal biopsies in particular showed
organizing peritonitis with rare palace
aiding and epithelioid granulomas so the
granulomas specifically were thought by
pathology to be related to the
pathogenesis of his disease process as
opposed to so tuberculosis is actually
the most common cause of these kinds of
findings that the skin testing for
tuberculosis had already been negative
as had been massive fasting so the
ascites secondary to primary bacterial
peritonitis has actually been reported
as an initial presentation so a rare one
of chronic granulomatous disease or CJD
and to follow that up they decided to
order an ANOVA test which we'll talk
about in just a moment
sarcoidosis was also considered on his
differential so eight levels were sent
for this the ACE levels did come back
negative but he was found to have a lack
of oxidative burst on his neutrophil
oxidative first assay which is in Nova
Nova assay and that's consistent with
what we see in CJD further testing
revealed that it's younger brother also
had CJD when they did follow up after
binding Timothy CJD and his mother was
printing to be a carrier although she
had been asymptomatic they did some
further genetic testing that showed that
his hemizygous for this B 1683 tube G
and that's been the cyp B gene
which while it hadn't really actually
been previously recorded in CJD this is
the first time it was consistent with a
diagnosis of x-linked ggd to DEET Tim
Z's done well on prophylactic
antibiotics and the family is
considering a bone-marrow transplant at
this time for him
so CJD itself is an x-linked or
autosomal recessive disorder of
phagocytes expense from a deficiency in
the NADPH oxidase which is required to
make reactive oxygen species that are
used to kill invading organisms as you
can see the Ohno of the organisms on the
right being killed NADPH oxidase result
in a rapid oxidative burst but CJD
patients can actually only use peroxide
from organisms that make reactive oxygen
species so there'd increased risk of
catalase positive organisms and this
inability to kill invading organisms is
actually what leads to the granulomas
that characterize CTD so if we look at a
little more closely at the mutations in
NADPH
the underlying defect is obviously the
impair generation of activates forms of
oxygen such as superoxide and
essentially due to a variety of
enzymatic defects that have been found
that lead to CJD and that involves the
NADPH oxidase system which is
multi-component
and it's required for the generation of
superoxide as well as their metabolites
hydrogen peroxide and bleach the
structural components of these are
referred to as [ __ ] enzyme pH so X which
is the fact that I phagocyte oxidase
proteins and you can see those slightly
in the upper right corner of the lower
box at rest the complex is the separate
components but they bind tightly as soon
as neutrophil activation occurs and that
forms that intact NADPH oxidase so this
complex actually harvests an electron
from NADPH and donates it to molecular
oxygen which creates the superoxide and
that is what's required for the
phagocytes micro micro
for phagocytes being able to kill
microbes mutations in the NADPH oxidase
components cause CJD and more than 50%
of CJD cases are actually from the
x-linked recessive trait it occurs only
in males for the x-linked but there is
also an autosomal recessive inherited
and heritability as well the common
mutations that are responsible for CJD
affect the GP 91 Sox which is the
x-linked form as well as several of the
other genes associated with the NADPH
complex
Nicolle features will often include
those listed and up to five percent of
these patients also have autoimmune
diseases laboratory features may include
anemia with an elevated CRP which we saw
in Timothy's case and they may also
demonstrate hyper gamma globulin emia
and a normal white blood cell count so n
BT which is also called Nova sorry n BT
which is nitro blue tetrazolium as well
as CHR which thr is also called referred
to as know about are the diagnostic
assays that we used to assess the
oxidative function of the NADPH oxidase
treatment generally tends to be
prophylactic anti microbials interferon
gamma and if the patient is a good
candidate for marrow transplant is
recommended to improve outcomes
looking at the the testing that we do
for that for CJD NBT and noba both
assess the lack of NADPH oxidase
function which is what is the heart of
CJD so the nitro booth tetrazolium a say
it was the most common diagnostic test
for CJD previously it's quite
straightforward and easy to run it's
based on direct reduction of n bt by
superoxide free radical to form an
insoluble clue for matthan in the normal
and the normal patient and then in the
absence of blue is what we see in the
CGT patient because they can't actually
convert the white yellow colourless
water-soluble compound it's been largely
replaced however by a slow site amount
of loes photometric ethics so that's by
Hydra rhodamine or dar SI also calls
Nova for neutrophil oxidative first a
same and now tends to be preferred it's
fast it's pretty easy to use and it can
actually distinguish x-linked from
autosomal patterns with CJD which is
helpful it's also very sensitive to low
numbers of functional neutrophils which
makes it great particularly in the
pediatric testing or do MBT continues to
be simple to perform and provides rapid
results and is still used in many
settings for both tests neutrophils have
to be activated that usually happens
with PMA to stimulate the oxidative
burst essentially once the diagnosis of
CJD is established a genetic analysis
might also be used to determine exactly
which mutation is the underlying cause
however all of them will be associated
with this lack of NADPH oxidase enzyme
activity
you
so elizabeth is our second case she came
to us as a five year old female with
well-controlled mild persistent asthma
she has allergic rhinitis and specific
IgE testing shows several environmental
allergens she also had a clinical
reaction to egg and pee and subsequently
demonstrated elevated specific IgE to
both of these components to setup or
response to a pneumococcal vaccine and a
history of two pneumonia recently she
was supposed to continue her current
asthma and allergy treatments and avoid
all food allergens
she was also considering immunotherapy
if her asthma remained well controlled
she was also revaccinated with a
pneumococcal vaccine to try to prevent
an additional pneumonia when she
presented to the immunology clinic this
is kind of our first blush with
Elizabeth and we didn't see her again
for actually six years because she was
being primarily followed outside our
system um six years later she came as an
11 year old female with the history of
asthma eczema had started her allergic
rhinitis and food allergies continued
and she was now experiencing more
recurrent MRSA skin infections and
wanted to be reevaluated again she was
primarily being followed locally by her
by an immunologist specialist in her
area but we were getting into the winter
months and she wanted to be reassessed
because their asthma pen tended to flare
in the winter
unfortunately this time leader her
asthma symptoms no longer seem to be
ideally controlled based on our ECT
score but she wasn't frequently using
her rescue inhaler and didn't have any
nighttime symptoms her pulmonary
function tests were promising so that
wasn't a super-high concern but we did
want to get that under better control
she was still elude avoiding her food
allergies which included green peas
peanuts and eggs and she hadn't actually
had a serious reaction to any of those
food allergies that required her EpiPen
for many years her specific IgE testing
also revealed an elevated IgE so it
turned out in discussing with her
parents it seems that there was a strong
family history with both her sister and
her paternal cousin having high IgG
levels that had also been discovered
during specific IgE testing and there
was a bit of rumor that that was also
happening in other paternal relatives as
they were tested for allergies she also
had eczema that seemed to be well
controlled with moisturizers overall and
even her elevated IgE as well as a
family history that her mother reported
she was referred to genetics for further
evaluation to see if she and her sister
who also had not been to genetics should
pursue any genetic testing for Hyper IgE
syndrome so at this point to the
immunologist also ordered repeat
quantitative immunoglobulins be in
t-cell subsets BBC ANCA tires so the
ANCA titers were actually ordered to
evaluate for us an affiliate granular
rhenium granulomatosis as well as
polyangiitis given her asthma allergic
rhinitis as well as her elevated
eosinophils she was found to have added
an adequate antibody titers to
diphtheria and was given a Tdap booster
at this particular visit and was told
that she needs to have those titers
checked six weeks post booster so we
could make sure that she was protected
well she didn't have any major
infections she has had two minor that is
required antibiotics in the last year
and it was notable as you can see here
we got a picture that she's been
retaining her baby teeth that were
starting to crack as her
dull teeth were growing in
so two years later Elizabeth again
returned to us after following up at the
outside clinic since her last visit
she'd again had multiple MRSA infections
severe asthma eczema and now a confirmed
family history of a bee hives and she
was presenting to be primary
immunodeficiency clinic for follow up
for this autosomal diamond dominant
hyper IGM IgE syndrome her genetic
testing was consistent with that of both
her sister and her paternal aunt and
that was a snap three mutation which is
very common in hyper IG syndrome and
it's likely a pathogenic variant that
we've got noted here she also had had a
few other things done since her last
visit she had two baby tooth pulse
due to retention she was found to have
scoliosis and she was getting a back
brace for that at the moment she's got
fatigue productive cough shortness of
breath - wheezing on exam her asthma's
not not improving decreased breath
sounds in the left lung fields overall
her picture was very concerning for
pneumonia with an asthma exacerbation
there wasn't any radiologic evidence of
pneumonia present but with her symptoms
being consistent with pneumonia and
poorly controlled severe asthma she was
at very high risk for developing
long-term pulmonary complications if if
it was a pneumonia that went untreated
so she was in period way treated with
antibiotic and steroid which would be
quite common in hyper IGM syndrome
so her quantitative immunoglobulins were
showing kind of across ages here and
they've continued to demonstrate
relatively normal levels of IgA IgG and
IgM for her age there's a slight
decrease in i GG and our most recent
testing IgE has consistently been
increased which is in keeping with your
diagnosis of autism dominant hybrid GE
syndrome an IgE at this level is
sometimes outside of the linear range of
the instrumentation and it's important
that validation be done that if the
illusion is going to happen on these
samples that are outside of the linear
range it's also important to note that
there are age-appropriate reference
ranges provided by the laboratory so is
the the immune systems developing the
appropriate level of immunoglobulins
change at each age and you can see how
much those reference ranges change as
she moves from five years to thirteen
years
you
looking a little bit at the variant
information associated with hyper IgE
syndrome so she has this stat3 mutation
that's likely pathogenic and it's also
associated with autosomal dominant and
mattel onset multi-system autoimmune
disease and that's because of the staff
to regain a function it's characterized
by early onset of autoimmune conditions
and multiple organ systems which can
include type 1 diabetes celiac disease
autoimmune and tropi p autoimmune how I
met illogic disease and there are other
commonly reported features short stature
primary hypothyroidism juvenile onset
arthritis interstitial lung disease
alopecia eczema which we sought for her
as well as nonspecific dermatitis
Hyper ID recurrent infection syndrome is
very common and we want to try to keep
these patients out of that so
identifying Piper IG early is very
important and it's really characterized
by triad of findings including recurrent
skin the abscesses ammonia's as well as
significantly elevated IgE levels with
onset and early childhood which we did
find here and her case common features
include eczema toy drachez candid itis
skeletal features include recurrent
fractures joint hypermobility vascular
abnormalities scoliosis which we did see
here and Elizabeth's case as well as the
retention of primary teeth and Elizabeth
had several of these things particularly
the school uses and the retention of
primary teeth which was seen in both her
and her sister and is a bit of a
giveaway for Hyper IgE syndrome most
affected individuals do survive into
adulthood but the life span can be
shortened due to complications with
cystic lung disease as well as recurrent
pneumonias
so overall hyper ID is associated with a
defect in neutrophil chemotaxis
it's most often autosomal dominant with
these mutations in step 3 and we know
that the th17 cells are impaired in
their maturation and neutrophil
recruitment is also impaired it's also
associated with inadequate
interferon-gamma response but the set
tree protein is actually involved in a
lot of systems besides just the immune
system and the mutation causes other
physiologic manifestations such as
skeletal abnormalities and really
unclear how the set mutations actually
lead to increased levels of IgE there's
been a reasonable amount of work on it
but we still haven't actually tease that
out
so hyper IgE syndrome is actually also
known as job syndrome and it's a rare
multi multi system primary
immunodeficiencies disorder the symptoms
often become apparent early during
infancy or childhood and it's
characterized by the repeat bacterial
infections as we were seeing with
Elizabeth of the skin and lungs
many of these skeletal abnormalities as
well as characteristic facial features
manifest themselves and the first
symptom is often development of a dry
red flaky skin rash such as eczema
efforts or early during infancy
researchers have looked at the mutations
from the stat3 genes that are causing
over 60% of the hybrids that are causing
hyper IgE and about 60% of patients with
hyper i g IG and most of these cases
actually occurs the result of a new
mutation in the gene there are two main
forms of hyper I J syndrome one is
inherited in the Abbott double dominant
pattern and one is in the autosomal
recessive pattern but both involved
defects and new means with them with
these elevated levels of immunoglobulin
G obviously unfortunately we don't have
any single diagnostic tests but the
elevated levels of total IgM allergy
testing are often the beginning of the
route to diagnosis for Hyper IG
boki three is Jane Jane came to us on
this hospital admission as a 2 year old
female she had aa Q acute aeneas
albinism and presented with a fever and
malaise that was uncharacteristic of her
usual rather spunky self her CBC
demonstrated mild anemia mild rhombus
eye Depina as well as mel neutropenia
she had lymph adenopathy and this was
actually a fourth infectious episode
this winter for which she's been given
antibiotics
she didn't do as well in the antibiotics
as being anticipated and a week later
her parents brought her back to the edy
she had an increased fever as well as
what Raji
at this hospital admission the CBC
confirmed the mild anemia as well as our
beside opinion neutropenia but
additionally the neutrophils contains
large granules and the reactive
lymphocytes contained a large eosin s
philip granules and there is concerned
that there might be a hematologic
ideology for some of the symptoms that
we're being noted so that prompted a
bone marrow aspiration in biopsy the
bone marrow examination revealed a might
be mildly hypothermic marrow and
granulocytes that contained abnormal and
large eosinophilic granule
so based on Ephesians history of a
cutaneous albinism as well as the
peripheral blood smear that had been
done and the bone marrow that both
contained large granules with no
leukocytes she was diagnosed with Shetty
act against Indra so DHS's is often
referred to is a rare autosomal
recessive disorder that presents with a
diverse collection of symptoms because
of the global effects of the mutated
gene the list gene which is also called
CHS one for obvious reasons is the
source of the defect and it provides
instructions for the lysosomal
trafficking regulator protein and we
think that that plays a role in the
transport or trafficking of materials
into like lysosomes but the full
function of that protein is still being
worked out granulocytes as well as
cytotoxic t-cells and patients with CHS
contain these very characteristic large
distinct granules with dysfunctional
lysosomes and these are incapable of
actually appropriately releasing
undergoing granule release and in
response
to bacterial or viral infections
the patients that present with CHS are
usually young children and they have
partial oculis cutaneous albinism which
is likely from a variant Milla Melania
Zone fusion within the melanocytes and
the option present with recurrent
pyogenic infections due to dysfunctional
granulocytes BHS results in recurrent
infections at an early age usually
showing up in infancy to early childhood
which is the case for Jane here at 2
years old
and that's usually their presenting
complaint the presence of the giant
granules and the white blood cells is
actually considered diagnostic so the
pattern that we see here is the
diagnostic lab tests for this
so case four is William William actually
presented a bit later than many of our
prior cases he was presenting for
follow-up as his pneumonia hadn't really
responded as quickly as anticipated
under prior treatment he was a full-term
birth and his reason bout with pneumonia
was the euroace form of pneumonia he has
a history of frequent I know pulmonary
infections and his CBC T and b-cell
subsets as well as quantitative
immunoglobulins were ordered to follow
up with this ammonia
so his CBC demonstrated neutropenia his
T and B cell subsets or normal but there
was some confusion around the
appropriate reference intervals for his
quantitative immunoglobulins they were
transferred into the EMR incorrectly
from an outside Hospital and there
wasn't any age appropriate reference
interval included on inquiry to the
outside Hospital where the testing was
run the listed reference in our wall was
given but the iGEM range seemed a little
bit low to the immunologist as well as
to the to our lab when we looked at it
so we pulled reference ranges from a few
institutions to aid in interpreting
Williams test results and when we looked
at it the question arose was his IgA
actually low or normal that depended a
little bit on which specific range you
were using and was his IgM slightly
elevated or was it normal he clearly had
a low IgG and a slightly low IgA with a
relatively normal IgM level so we
verified the age appropriate reference
intervals and that was all determined
but if it's important as we're
implementing many of these tests that
age-appropriate reference intervals are
included particularly in Pediatrics as
the immune system is still changing
quickly in kids as they're developing
and the reference intervals can actually
change in every year as they develop and
these deficiencies really will only be
had if an appropriate interval is used
for comparison
so given the low IgG and IgA and the
normal IGF follow-up testing was done
and William was diagnosed with x-linked
hyper IGM syndrome so x-linked hyper IgM
is actually caused by the absence or
mutation of cd40 ligand which is usually
expressed to unactivated
t cd4 T lymphocytes the absence of C D
154 actually interrupts the cell
differentiation by somatic hypermutation
and the heavy chain switch from I Jam to
other isotypes in this case the B cells
end up only producing IgM because they
can't undergo the heavy chain class
switching and the IgM levels can be
normal or elevated patients with the
x-linked form may have severe
neutropenia which we saw some
neutropenia and William and they often
prevent during infancy and it's very
characteristic that they have this
pneumo Pneumocystis euro fetch e
pneumonia lymphoid tissue is often very
small because the deficient cd40 ligand
signaling doesn't activate b-cells
otherwise the clinical presentation is
quite similar to x-linked a.m. globulin
emia and can include recurrent pyogenic
bacterial sign of pulmonary infections
during the first or second year of life
there are so in addition to be excellent
form there at least for autosomal
recessive forms that are involved that
involve a BSL defect into these forms
that I've listed here the serum IgM
levels are actually much higher than in
the x-linked form so we would definitely
see the IgM coming up at two or more
times the upper reference range and
they're associated with lymphoid
hyperplasia as well as autoimmune
disease or disorders are much more
likely to be present present and
leukopenia can also be seen the
diagnosis hyper IgM syndrome is usually
suspected based on clinical criteria and
the serum IgM levels are measured normal
or elevated serum IgM levels and low
levels or absence of IgG and IgA also
support this diagnosis usual follow-up
testing will include flow cytometry of
the t4 like an expression on t-cell
surfaces and what possible the diagnosis
is usually confirmed by genetic testing
although that's not really required
other laboratory findings that we might
see as we're testing these kits include
a reduced number of memory B cells which
would be the C d-27 marker as well as an
absence of class which to memory B cells
often IG d c d 27
so when we try to put x-linked hyper IGM
in the context of the immune system we
can see that the mature B cell is
present but there's actually a block in
the ability to class switch so that's
going to show itself it's the X h-i-m
that's showing it about the middle of
the screen you can see there are three
boxes right about the middle that are
preventing that class switching to IgG
IgE and IgA so we're only ending up with
the IgM that decreases IgG ami
production obviously but IgM is intact
the class switching the lesser mutation
of the cd40 ligand actually impairs the
B cell differentiation by somatic
hypermutation and the heavy chain switch
harm I gem to other isotypes and the
presence of cytokines normal cd40 ligand
interacts with the B cells as you can
see in the center I must signal them to
switch from producing IgM to producing
IG AG or E but in the x-linked hyper IGM
syndrome the T cells lack functional cd4
T so there's no signal actually
happening to the B cells to switch
that's how we end up with just a GM
you
so a few of the clinical features again
the opportunistic infections as as well
as some rare forms of pneumonia are very
common the in terms of laboratory the
elevated to normal IgM in the basis of
decreased IgG and IgA is a major
giveaway for this and pancytopenia is
not uncommon so usually you're looking
at prophylaxis for for this with
antibiotics IVIG is also very common and
bone marrow transplant it is very
helpful as well
so Charlotte came to us a little bit
older
she was an 11 year old female that
presented with her parents her brother
for evaluation for possible primary
immunodeficiency her parents reported
that when she was a young child she had
constant rhinorrhea as well as ear eggs
she was treated with multiple oral
over-the-counter antihistamines and
nasal sprays but there was just no
improvement finally her tonsils and
adenoids were removed but she continued
to have what her parents described as
lagging colds she had skin prick testing
done to look for aero allergens and
reportedly that was negative she also
had ma has a mild persistent asthma and
up and well controlled she hasn't had to
have any oral steroids for the last year
a few years ago she also reported having
constant nausea and constipation and had
been referred to GI there her parents
report that she had normal scopes and pH
probes performed as part of the
evaluation but in the course of the
workup the gastroenterologist actually
obtained serum immunoglobulins and noted
that they were all somewhat low so she
was at that time told that she should
follow up with her PCP who continued to
monitor her immunoglobulin levels and
she was ultimately referred to a private
allergist for continued surveillance she
had had her immunoglobulins followed as
well as vaccine titers and had been told
in the past that she had lost lost all
of her immunity to her vaccines her
mother reports that she's been
clinically diagnosed with chickenpox as
well three times despite having been
vaccinated her parents and Charlotte
both reported that she's never really
feeling good she's always low on energy
and they asked me that she misses about
20 days of school a year for illness
so thinking back to all of the things we
should be concerned about for primary
immunodeficiency she checks several of
those boxes so when we look at her
current testing we see markedly
decreased ITA
let's perhaps a very slightly low IgG
and a normal IgM her IgG subclasses also
all come up essentially normal as well
for CBC her beazell panel as well as her
Tia and B cell counts her complement was
also normal and she seems to have
retained her tetanus tighter so she had
a booster six weeks prior and her titers
came back normal and she also had an
essentially normal detail panel and she
hasn't needed any antibiotics from sir
visits last spring although again coming
into winter that that may change
so given all of this Charlotte seemed
that to likely have a selective IgA
deficiency with a variable response to
vaccines selective i GA deficiency is
very common among primary
immunodeficiencies and is also often
associated with an IgG subclass
deficiency and so subclasses were
ordered and that's usually an IgG to
suppress deficiency although IHG 4 has
also been noted as of this time they
went ahead and started her on September
through May prophylactic antibiotic
treatment to reduce your winter time
infections and decided to to move
forward with conservative treatment as
there were no major symptoms that they
felt we required IVIG at at the time
so the Selective IgA deficiency is the
most common and mildest of the B cell
immunodeficiency disorders
most patients are asymptomatic and the
finding often is incidental to other
testing these patients are at an
increased risk for respiratory and GI
infections and are characterized by low
levels or complete absence of IgA we
thought low levels here with Charlotte
looking again back at our immune system
overview of b-cell immunodeficiency
disorders we can see that selective IgA
deficiency has a pretty small effect on
the full b-cell component of the immune
system so you can see down in the bottom
right corner the effects only happening
in that small part of the diagram and so
many of these patients are asymptomatic
Charles came to us as an eight-year-old
boy he presented for further evaluation
of some abdominal pain he'd been having
as well as altered stooling patterns
because he's had the symptoms for quite
a while but they seem to be more
frequent since he started school this
year and look like they're associated
with stress he hasn't had any weight
loss no appetite concerns no reflux
vomiting trigger few trigger foods that
seem to be associated with the symptoms
but there is a significant family
history of irritable bowel syndrome
part of his testing included a workup
for celiac disease related to this and
his tissue transglutaminase iga as was
its diiemma dated grade and peptide iga
were ordered but the laboratory couldn't
report them
quantity of immunoglobulins actually
that were ordered at the same time
revealed that Charles had an
undetectable level of IgA making IgA
celiac serologies not useful the IgG
serologies were run instead and both for
negative while employment or bowel
syndrome has been reported in IgA
deficiency the physician that was
treating Charles didn't feel that the
current symptoms were actually related
to its IgA status he likely has a
selective IgA deficiency but at the
moment he appears asymptomatic and
making Charles just another coincidental
iga deficiency diagnosis codes come
through our doors and IgA deficient
patients the common finding is a
maturation defect in B cells to produce
IgA
however the genetic basis of selective
IgA deficiency actually still remains
unclear and at least some cases it
appears to involve the stem cells as IgA
deficiency has been transferred by bone
marrow transplantation in some cases the
prognosis is good in patients with IgA
deficiency if it's not associated with
significant disease which is helpful we
also found that IJ deficiency and
children can resolve over time at the
same time IgA deficiency can also
progress to common variable
immunodeficiency which has a less
favourable outcome because of that child
is being followed for clinical and
immunological findings related to his
IgA deficiency
so our takeaways from today and from all
of the kids that we've seen looking at
the four step testing for primary
immunodeficiencies starts with CBC and
quantitative immunoglobulins as we find
many of these cases these two tests were
enough to indicate to us that there was
a primary immunodeficiency it and that
follow-up was necessary
age appropriate age appropriate
reference ranges are vital to be able to
catch many of the primary
immunodeficiencies many PID tests
require live cells pre analytical
processes then that have to be carefully
implemented to make sure that the cells
the cells remain viable for the testing
that's being done via flow cytometry
laboratory testing is vital for
diagnosis of primary immunodeficiency as
well as for rule out of all of the
differential diagnosis that we see
associated with so many of these kids
and the same primary immunodeficiency
can have many manifestations so it's
important for us to think zebra I'd like
to acknowledge Department of Pathology
and the division of clinical immune of
pathology at UPMC as well as the
division of pediatric allergy and
immunology University of Pittsburgh's
Department of Pathology as well as the
patients and families at UPMC and I'll
take any questions
Thank You dr. wheeler for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
our first question is for the p.i stages
of testing IgG sub-class analysis is
mentioned as part of step 2 can you
further elaborate on subclass testing
definitely
so subclasses are pretty standard either
as an in lab assay or send out a say
when there's suspicion of a primary
immunodeficiency but the primary
isotypes IgG a and M are coming back
normal it's necessary for us to look at
subclasses to determine if an
immunoglobulin subclass deficiency is
actually the root of the symptoms we're
seeing IgG subclass deficiencies can be
in any one or combination of the four
IgG subclasses 1 2 3 or 4 and
particularly when total IgG is within
the normal age specific reference range
do we need to be looking at subclass
testing if we also use the class testing
a lot in patients that have specific IgA
deficiency because it's not uncommon to
see iga deficiency coexisting with a
subclass deficiency and that changes the
risk stratification for these patients
the most common subclass deficiency with
IgA is IgG - although IgG 4 is sometimes
seen as well and as we just talked about
IgA deficiency can also evolve into the
more severe common variable
immunodeficiency that is at
because it can evolve into cvid a little
bit more frequently as that's happening
often there's a decrease in IgG
subclasses that occur before a decrease
in total IgG and so we can be more
proactive with our treatment if we
detect that decrease in subclasses first
we also use subclasses as a part of
looking at those that have symptomatic
IgA deficiency regularly to be able to
catch that cbid
change also in trying to diagnose common
variable immunodeficiency by itself that
is a very complex set of tests and many
of the algorithms include subclass
testing we also use the class
measurement in determining a
revaccination strategy so some subclass
deficiencies are correlated with a lack
of vaccine response for example IgG 2
deficiency in patients which have an
antibody responses to only a subset of
polysaccharides in the 23 valent pneumo
vaccine has been has been noted it's
probably also worth discussing that on
finding a subclass deficiency it's
important that we follow up measurement
a few weeks two months later to confirm
that the deficiency is not a transient
deficiency and then also that we do
further testing including poor antibody
response to vaccine challenge before we
can classify a clinically significant
deficiency in IgG subclasses and begin
treatment
you now what specific tests do you
recommend when selective ie a deficiency
is suspected great question
so diagnostic testing is really first
line is the quantitative immunoglobulins
for this so we see that that's how
asymptomatic iga deficiency is often
found has happened in our last case i GG
subclass testing can help to determine
if there's also an underlying subclass
deficiency that may increase patient
risk for infection or poor vaccine
response if the patients for them with
symptoms that could be consistent with
an occult infection we obviously have to
do the relevant microbiology testing to
be performed with particular attention
to opportunistic infection possibilities
in this immune compromised patient
subsets other common comorbidities that
may require testing and attention in IgA
deficiency I believe it's about a
quarter of patients that have
symptomatic selective IgA deficiency
that also has autoimmune diseases so
rheumatoid arthritis eczema lupus are
all reasonably common and obviously
appropriate referral to a Rheumatologist
and testing with CRP are anti-ccp or AAA
may be indicated if that's consistent
with their clinical symptoms celiac
disease may also be more common in these
patients and IgG testing for tissue
transglutaminase and deaminated gliadin
peptide can help with this diagnosis
obviously we're looking for the IgG
components since they are IgA negative
and again only if symptoms are present
and we also see that asthma and other
allergies are common in selective IgA
deficiency patients so those can be
followed up with either skin prick test
or serum specific IgE testing those are
kind of the main tests that can help to
make sure that we're catching these
patients and helping them to have a good
quality of life
thank you can you further comment on idg
to subclass deficiency yeah so I did you
to subclass deficiency is definitely
more common in children than adults and
as we've talked about it's not uncommon
that it's associated with IgA deficiency
it's mostly responsible for antibody
response to probably saccharide antigens
so pneumonias and other Sano pulmonary
infections predominate this clinical
picture the lack of response to the
pneumococcal polysaccharide vaccine
often triggers testing for IG g2
deficiency and in terms of development
in Pediatrics the IgG 2 levels actually
rise more slowly to adult levels than
other subclasses so the age-appropriate
reference ranges are even more important
for IgG 2 it also means that an
incidental finding of a low IgG to
subclass measurement and children and
the absence of significant symptoms
should be monitored but may not be of
concern as the child may outgrow it and
even symptomatic IgG 2 deficiency in
childhood may normalize with age the
literature varies quite a bit with as
many as 80% to as few as 30 percent of
children thought to kind of outgrow this
IgG 2 deficiency but progression to
common variable immunodeficiency is a
concern so following this up in both
children and adults to make sure that
there's no progression to CVID is very
important
right thank you it looks like we have
time for one more question okay it says
you mentioned in case number four
Williams but there is confusion around
appropriate reference intervals of qit
can you please further expand on that
definitely so in Williams case we
received quantitative immunoglobulin
results from an outside Hospital and
there had been some issue with the
outside hospitals data getting into our
EMR you don't specifically remember if
there were no ranges or if the ranges
that they had appended were adult ranges
but one of those two and so there were
not appropriate reference ranges
available to him thankfully he was being
reviewed by an immunologist so she
immediately flagged that there was not
an appropriate reference range for his
IgG levels and call down to the lab so
we were able to get ahold of the outside
lab and get their age appropriate
reference ranges but those still seemed
a little bit off particularly for the
IgM so we ended up looking at reference
ranges our own in-house as well as a few
other institutions to try to help tease
out his diagnosis at the end of the day
verifying reference ranges and
Pediatrics generally is very tough and
particularly in immunoglobulins because
they change every you've one to two
years as a child immune system develops
the very important if you can't verify
the package insert reference ranges
twenty twenty kids in each of the
reference ranges can be very difficult
particularly in the very young ages and
if that can't be done thorough
literature searching as well as
attention to population characteristics
is very important and Method comparison
can actually yield an appropriate
equation if you want to try to transfer
reference intervals between methods and
that's particularly helpful in
Pediatrics a lot of our first-line
screening with quantitative
immunoglobulins is actually done by
primary care physicians and that are the
child's pediatrician and so there's a
great need for this to turn red in the
EMR so that we're paying attention to
things that are abnormal and because of
that the reference range is very
important recently there has been a lot
of movement or
it's more accurate pediatric reference
ranges generally and immunoglobulins
have been a little bit slow and being
included but it looks like hopefully on
the horizon we have some updated studies
coming up that will help us have perhaps
more improved reference ranges in peds
thank you again dr. wheeler for your
time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor binding site for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions any questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed to speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand and laboratory Lert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time bye